the world number one tennis player novak
djokovic has been denied entry to
australia less than two weeks before the
start of the australian open tennis
tournament djokovic had his visa revoked
after being held at melbourne airport
for several hours before he left for
australia he said he'd been granted a
medical exemption to take part in the
grand slam without being vaccinated
against covert 19. djokovic says he will
file a court injunction to stop his
deportation
a short while ago australian prime
minister scott morrison had this to say
about the tennis star
on the issue of mr djokovic
rules
are rules
and there are no special cases
entry with a visa requires double
vaccination
or a medical exemption
i'm advised that such an exemption was
not in place and as a result
he is subject to the same rule as anyone
else now to talk us through the story
i'm joined by tennis commentator steve
pearce in melbourne good to see you
again steve
after apparently being granted an
exemption from vaccination uh from the
vaccination requirement
djokovic has now had his visa revoked
what what happened
that's a good question again um it's
something that people are trying to
piece together now um in melbourne it's
obviously it's what everyone's talking
about so basically what it seems is
although victoria the victorian state
government and its process with tennis
australia uh involving medical expertise
to decide whether to permit him to play
in the tournament or not that medical
medical exemption was approved for novak
djokovic then
he's
very publicly declared that and jumped
on a flight which possibly now looking
back wasn't the best thing to do could
have come in a bit more low-key anyway
he's jumped on a flight and arrived at
melbourne airport uh late last night
australia time it's what 10 o'clock in
the morning now
here in melbourne
and the border force which is
run by the federal government who look
after the actual borders of australia
rather than victoria the australian open
have looked at his visa and looked at
the supporting evidence with that around
the medical exemption and have decided
that that is not sufficient to to gain
entry to australia and they have
contacted the state government last
night and asked whether the state
government would do anything further to
support
novak djokovic's entry
into australia
the state government has said no we
can't do anything further to support it
this is how it is and therefore the
australian border force has made the
decision to cancel his visa and is
aiming to deport him today back to
serbia but there is more to play out
potentially in the courts
i mean there's been a lot of negative
reaction and a lot of strong feelings in
australia since well since we talked 24
hours ago
what are people saying now what's the
reaction now to this latest news
they're pretty much flabbergasted um you
know everyone who didn't want him to
come anyway is just saying well that's
great you know turn him around get him
out of here but i think overall the
sense is just that um how could it come
to this how could it be
that the two processes that should be
far more aligned and far smoother i mean
you've got a situation where you have
state governments here in australia and
i know this is the case in some other
countries around the world but state
governments who are responsible for a b
and c
and then federal governments responsible
for d e and f and the two
just not meeting not not talking not
understanding the process but you know
there's that and so how did it come to
that but also from novak djokovic's
position um and his team how could it be
that that these visa requirements were
not ticked off
so robustly before he took that
photograph and announced that he was on
his way to australia i mean everyone
knows that getting into a country with
the right visa requirements is
absolutely the first thing you have to
deal with so so the the reaction really
here is just
everyone throwing their hands up in the
air really and everyone's blaming each
other the victorian government blaming
the federal government vice versa it's a
mess and it's actually quite
embarrassing for the country i think as
well you know um it's one thing to be
firm and you know the rules apply to
everyone but don't don't let it come to
this surely this could have been sorted
out before he actually got on flight
all right
tennis commentator for australian open
radio steve pearce thank you for your
insights thanks ella